chanting woman life Freedom thousands of
people gathered at aichi Cemetery in
Kurdistan Province the final resting
place of Masa amini mourners are heard
calling their Province the fascist
graveyard hours later this was the scene
in the city of sakas
as Security Forces fought with people
semi-official news agencies say nearly
10 000 came out to Mark the 40th Day
since Masa amini died in police custody
in Tehran
University students across the country
also remembered her this group is
singing from the blood of the Youth of
the Homeland tulips have grown
scuffles broke out in another University
across the city
and police use tear gas to disperse
students in at least two institutions in
Tehran the student protests were not
just in the capital but across the
country this was a scene in the city of
karach with many chanting freedom and in
the second largest city mashad students
have been protesting since the death of
Masa amini last month protests are not
limited to only schools this is tehran's
Grand Bazaar on Wednesday
Masa was visiting relatives with her
brother in the capital when she was
detained by the so-called morality
police for not wearing the mandatory
headscarf properly the police released
the security camera footage saying it
shows Masa arriving at a facility for
so-called re-education class on the
religious benefits of wearing a
headscarf according to the official
autopsy and a government investigation
Masa had a pre-existing health condition
and suffered a heart attack her family
says this is not true and says she was
beaten while in custody government
supporters also rallied across the
country the president addressed the
issue in a live televised interview
I told her family that this news was
shocking not just for me but for every
Iranian criticism and Dialogue on
various issues have a place in the
Constitution and can help us in the
decision-making process but the
distinction between protest and Riot
should be defined earlier this month
president raisy visited an all-female
University in Tehran where he praised
the achievements of women in Academia at
the same time these University students
chanted raisy get lost outside the
building this is the area where Iran's
morality police arrested NASA amini on a
Tuesday afternoon since then they
haven't been seen much in the city
whatever happens next year regardless of
which version of events people believe
it is clear that masamini's death has
changed this country
dorsa chapari Al Jazeera Tehran